des départements vert orange ou rouge
telles sont les nouvelles couleurs de la
france présenté par le ministre de la
santé
olivier ferrand à peine annoncée cette
carte suscite déjà les interrogations
concernant son interprétation les
départements classés verts sont ceux
susceptibles d'être des confiné selon le
protocole annoncé les collégiens
devraient donc retrouver le chemin de
l'école à partir du 18 mai les jardins
publics et les parcs rouvriront
également dans ces zones où la
circulation du virus est jugée faible
pour les départements en rouge au
contraire le taux d'infection ainsi que
le nombre de personnes hospitalisées
sont à ce jour encore trop élevé si la
situation sanitaire dans ces
départements n'évolue pas positivement
d'ici le 7 mai la rentrée des collégiens
n'aura pas lieu le 18 mai comme annoncé
et les espaces verts resteront clos les
préfectures et mairies quant à elle se
réserveront le droit de rouvrir ou non
les écoles primaires
reste à déterminer dans les prochains
jours le sort des départements en orange
ces derniers sont susceptibles de passer
en verre ou en rouge selon leur
évolution
une carte qui fait déjà polémique en
effet la haute corse et tonnes de son
classement en rouge alors que la corse
du sud plus touchée est elle placée dans
le vert
le poumon était beaucoup plus impactée
en verre et le schisme t ou les trois
critères sont beaucoup plus favorables
en rouge la carte publié ce soir par le
gouvernement laisse les corses plus que
perplexe nous attendons des explications
l' agence régionale de la santé de corse
a déclaré avoir relevé un problème de
comptage et a reconnu que ce classement
était une erreur pour la haute corse
d'autres départements seraient concernés
et ont d'ailleurs manifesté leur
incompréhension face à cette carte la
carte provisoire publié ce soir classe
le département du cher en rouge par
erreur après échange avec monsieur le
préfet et la rs nous avons demandé une
rectification rapide
une heure avant sa divulgation je me
suis entretenu avec le directeur de
notre centre hospitalier qui me
confirmait que nous n'avions jamais eu
si peu de cas en réanimation avec une
seule personne prise en charge alors ce
zonage reste inexplicable c'est une
catastrophe
imaginez les conséquences pour nous en
terme de tourisme et de déconfinement et
l'état d'esprit des parents d'élèves et
des enseignants ce soir alors que nous
préparons la rentrée le 12 mai des
changements sont donc à prévoir puisque
cette configuration est amené à
lui est chaque jour jusqu'au 7 mai
prochain au delà de cette date la carte
sera cristallisé afin de mettre en
oeuvre des confinement du 11 mai elle
est